what scriptures you would suggest for
refuting solo well go through Matthew 7
and go to Matthew 25 and show where
Jesus says not everyone says Lord Lord
to the kingdom but those who do the will
of my Father in Heaven that's Matthew
7:21-23 and then Matthew 25
31-46 so say here Jesus says you will
be rewarded for your obedience to his
law or you'll be condemned by not OB his
law because he says he who does the will
of my father shall enter the kingdom he
says it Matthew
72123 read all the way to 27 and Matthew
2531 46 for starters and then when he
tries to tell you that the Bible teaches
solid what it says you're justified by
faith not by The Works of law say yeah
that's not Paul's Point Paul is talking
about is that the Jews are insisting
that you need to observe the Torah in
order to be rewarded with
immortality Paul's point is no it's not
the works of the law it's faithfulness
to Christ and here's where people get
confused what he means by faith is he
means faithfulness and I'm going to give
you the verses Paul tells you what he
means by faith because he cites habakuk
habakuk chapter 2 verse4 habakuk habakuk
chapter 2 ver4 however you want to
pronounce it he cites that passage three
times because I believe Paul Hebrews is
from Paul he uses
uis to write it but it's his it's his
sermon he uses habak 2:4 in Romans
11:17 Galatians
3:1 and Hebrews
1038 go back and look at the Hebrew of
habakuk or habakuk 24 it says the just
shall live by his faith the word faith
imuna means by his faithfulness the
righteous will live by being faithful so
for Paul faith is being faithful to
God what his he was debating is the Jews
were saying the only way you can be
faithful to God is keep the works of the
law Torah he goes no being faithful or
having faith that justifies you is being
committed to doing what God tells you to
do when he tells you to do it so before
the law of Moses how Abraham faithful
how did he have faith by doing what God
told him to do during the time of Moses
how does someone show that he has true
Faith how does he or she show that he's
faithful by doing the law of Moses now
that Christ has come having faith being
faithful is to obey the commands of
Christ that's all he's saying faith for
Paul means faithful being faithful
that's what James is saying the true
faith is the faith that is working
obeying being faithful the dead faith is
the faith that's simply mental
Ascent okay so Paul that's his view of
Faith being faithful and how do I know
again let me remind you he cites habakuk
chapter 2 verse4 in Romans
1:17 Galatians 3:11 Hebrews
10:38
there gives you definition of what faith
is for Paul it's not fed it's fedusa
being faithful because if you go back
look at your lexican at habach 24 the
word faith there in Hebrew is amuna it
means to be faithful the righteous shall
live by his faithfulness faithfulness to
what to what God demands so during the
time Moses being faithful having faith
is to do the law but at the time of
Christ it's not doing the law it's being
faithful to what God tells you now God
tells me that faith that saves is being
faithful to Christ his meaning is
completely different from what they're
saying but if you de calvane and Delane
the Bible and remove these Protestant
lenses everything now makes sense I hope
that helps so let me ask you is this the
correct way to say it yes um
so Grace is something freely given to us
obviously I think everyone here
acknowledges that faith is how
we take hold of that Grace but our faith
is dead without our works which justify
us yeah see now you're you're defining
Faith to mean trust and having true
trust is to obey
right having true trust is to obey yes
yeah because when you say faith without
works is dead what what do you mean by
that meaning that if I truly have faith
in you that means I truly trust you and
if I trust you I'll take you out your
word to do what you tell me right yes
okay so that's that's one way of
defining it but the way I'm defining it
is that faith is being faithful
so I don't distinguish works from Faith
now James does that because he's dealing
with a group that are antinomians
they're Lawless they think oh just by
saying Jesus is Lord that's good enough
he goes no the demons know Jesus lord
they're going to
hell so he's distinguishing the other
day say it again I brought that up to my
friend the other day I keep saying I
tell him the demons believed yeah but
here's where the Protestants read their
protestantism into the passage they say
yeah yeah we agree because the faith
that saves is never alone
it is a working Faith well if you really
listen to yourself Protestant you're
basically saying you're saved by
faithfulness yeah but see they're so
blinded by the Protestant tradition
they're not hearing what they just said
they're just agreeing with the Catholic
Orthodox view the view of the early
church the faith that saves is never
alone it is a working Faith oh so you're
saved by faithfulness yeah okay so you
just destroy so is defined by Martin
Luther and doesn't James 2:26 say were
justified by works literally well it
says just as the body without the spirit
is dead so too faith without works is
dead that's what James 226 says so there
is no faith that doesn't have works just
like the body cannot be alive without
the spirit but what you want to do I'm
going to show you something James 2:25
says that Rahab was justified how can
you read that similarly similarly also
Raba RAB RAB Rahab Rahab okay the Harlot
was she not justified by works by
receiving The Messengers and sending
them out through another way now how was
Rahab Justified she was she not
justified by works she by works right
James is saying Yeah by works yeah but
you know what Hebrews 11:31 says that
was Hebrews 11:31 guys pay attention
James 2:25 uses the same example that
Hebrews does now watch okay now read
Hebrews 11:31
by faith Rahab the Harlot did not perish
with the unbelievers after receiving the
spies with peace wow guys what James
called Works Hebrews called Faith here
it is James 2:25 says in the same way
was not Rahab the Harlot also justified
by works by what she did when she
received the messengers and sent them
out by another way the same exact
example Hebrews uses and calls it Faith
here it is I want did you to see it
Hebrews 11:31 Brethren Hebrews
11:31 same example of James but here
Hebrews calls it Faith by faith Rahab
the Harlot did not perish along with
those who were dism minuted after
welcoming the spies in peace so what she
did is called Faith but James says that
is works that justifi her okay I'm
confused James 2:25 in the same way was
not Rahab also justified by works when
she received the messenger sent them out
by another way but Hebrews 11:31 says
that is what faith is she was justified
by faith Hebrews 11:31 so you understand
why I keep saying faith means to be
faithful faith is being faithful being
faithful means you have to do so this is
true Faith being
faithful so this false dichotomy between
faith and works you cannot separate
works from Faith because it's dead just
like if you separate the spirit from the
body it's dead Faith is doing faith is
obeying faith is being faithful that's
what true Sola is solely by your
faithfulness that's it in the story man
you can then turn the tables against him
saying hold on Buddy you know believing
is a work do you know Jesus says
believing is a work so if you're not
justified by works then you're not
justified by believing either John 6:27
29 Brethren says believing is a work you
do believing is a work you do so if you
don't understand what Paul means you're
not justify by works you're gonna have a
whole lot of contradictions if you're a
Protestant John 62729 this is
Jesus Yep this is Jesus saying it yeah
therefore they said to him what should
we do so that we may labor in the works
of God Jesus responded and said to them
this is the work of God that you believe
in him who he sent wow but no but the
believing is present active par that you
are believing are believing right okay
but wait he said believing is a work you
must do yeah because faith is
required so the claim that you're not
justified by works but by faith if you
don't understand what Paul meant you
just created a contradiction between
Jesus and Paul and the Liberals and
Muslims are going to love you because
Jesus said believing is a work you must
do in order to obtain the food that will
result in eternal life you skipped 27
but that's okay you got it now right oh
yeah I got it guys you need to know this
good commentary will help you or you can
look at Bible Hub inter line and tell
you the tense present active participle
present tense means ongoing so literally
it says the believing ones
the believing ones in other words belief
is ongoing well how do you continuously
believe how are you
believing if that doesn't mean you are
obeying because to be believing means
that you're trusting Christ to do what
he tells you so John 3:16 didn't help
his case say wait wait wait it says the
believing ones meaning that it's an
ongoing continuous active belief I am
beling so what happens if you stop
believing well John 15 tells you then
you're cut off if you don't you're not
abiding in Christ and Jesus even says
John 14232 24 believing is to do his
Commandments and if you're not doing his
Commandments that shows you're not
believing and that you hate him John
14:23 to 24 Jesus responded and said to
him if anyone loves me he shall keep my
word and my father will love him and we
will come to him
and we will make our dwelling place with
him whoever does not love me does not
keep my words and the word that you have
heard is not of me but it is of the
father who sent me so if you don't keep
his word do you love
him nope are you believing in him if you
don't keep his word nope so that's what
believing in him is it's to be faithful
to do what he
commands that's it in the story brother
help you because after he doesn't listen
you're wasting your time yeah because
you can say you love your wife but if
you're cheating on her then do you
really love her exactly so that means
it's being faithful to your Covenant
partner right right yep because marriage
is a covenant to lover is to be faithful
to your Covenant partner that's it end
of story